Jeremy Corbyn facing in all directions
while trying to look like he knows where
he's going on a day he addresses the
stickiest topic of all the labor leader
taking the stage in his first brexit
speech since 2018 all political parties
keen to make it look like they'll bring
the brexit crisis to a swift decisive
conclusion after the election a Labour
government will get brexit sorted within
six months by giving you the British
people the final say this time the
choice will be between leaving with a
sensible deal or remaining in the EU
that is the policy it really isn't very
complicated not complicated he says but
few politicians would claim that it was
his goal to appear like he's not picking
a side while also promising a second
referendum which most brexit ears don't
want people sometimes accuse me of
trying to talk to both sides at once in
the brexit debate so people who voted
leave and people who voted remain do you
know what they're dead right labour
stands not just for the 52 percent or
the 48 percent but for the 99 percent
meanwhile Boris Johnson hoping for a
positive reaction to his own campaign
message the choice before the country is
really very clear do you want to go
forward with our agenda which is to get
brexit done and then get on with
delivering all the wonderful things we
want to do for this country in 2020 or
do you want to waste 2020 which could be
an absolutely fantastic year for the
nation with two more referendums Boris
Johnson says he wants to get brexit done
but which side would actually wrap the
issue up faster labour now they want an
entirely new renegotiation with the
European Union and a referendum on
Britain's membership within six months
but if the remain side win then will you
really be sorted then there's the
Conservatives they want to leave legally
the European Union almost immediately
but then negotiate a free-trade
agreement within 12 months experts and
even so
members of the cabinet doubt that that's
possible she isn't going to go away
quickly but for some it is over as of
now
Justine greening elected four times as a
Conservative MP reflecting on 2015 being
the crucial turning point that was the
first brexit election in the way by 2017
we've gone from a 10,000 majority down
to a one and a half thousand majority my
concern for the preserved party is it's
32 years since we've all in a landslide
and I think the last time we did win a
landslide it was when we put opportunity
at the center of what we were talking
about and meant it and the reality is
because of brexit it's very hard to do
that whether or not you want to it is
really hard to do that because this
whole political system of ours
necessarily has to focus on this biggest
issue if you like project facing Britain
which is how we leave the European Union
stepping away for the last time just
like former cabinet colleague Philip
Hammond who today also announced he will
not be contesting this election either
change is coming but gone will be many
other faces the public recognise now Sam
Cote Sky News